digamos que este de aquí soy yo muy bien
y que me encuentro flotando en el
espacio y voy a llamar a mi marco de
referencia es verdad mi marco de
referencia será ese y todo evento en
este marco de referencia tendrá
coordenadas x coma siete verdad como lo
hemos hecho hasta este momento en todos
los vídeos anteriores entonces cualquier
punto en el espacio-tiempo tendrá
coordenadas x 7 y digamos que tenemos
digamos aquí tenemos a mi amiga verdad
es mi amiga de siempre que está viajando
en una nave espacial y esa nave espacial
tiene una velocidad relativa de verdad
con respecto a mi marco de referencia
verdad y el marco de referencia para mi
amiga vamos a llamarlo s prima y tendrá
coordenadas x prima 7 prima
vamos a introducir a un tercer personaje
digamos que tenemos otro personaje que
se esté moviendo en esta nave espacial y
que tenga cierta velocidad y que vamos a
pensar que es el cambio en la coordenada
x dividido entre el cambio en t muy bien
entonces con esta información veamos si
podemos deducir una forma para saber
cuál sería esta velocidad delta x entre
delta t pero no en mi marco de
referencia como se encuentra aquí sino
en el marco de referencia s prima es
decir el de mi amiga verdad
es decir lo que nosotros queremos
calcular es el cambio en x prima
dividido entre el cambio en t prima muy
bien entonces así sabríamos la velocidad
en el marco de referencia s prima
entonces en realidad esto es directo
verdad vamos a vamos a tratar de hacerlo
vamos a calcular el cambio en x prima
verdad vamos a calcular lo primero y
esto
será igual a quién bueno pues será igual
la gama verdad como lo hemos visto en el
vídeo anterior verdad gama que
multiplica al cambio en x menos beta por
el cambio en 7 verdad es simplemente
aplicarle la transformación del lawrence
al cambio en x y al cambio en 7 muy bien
entonces ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es dividir esto entre el cambio en t
prima pero antes de eso tenemos que
recordar quién es el cambio en sete
prima verdad que era lo que nosotros
pudimos calcular en el vídeo anterior
verdad esto simplemente será ce veces el
cambio entre prima y esto será igual a
gamma o al menos como a mí me gusta
siempre ponerlo será gamma que
multiplica a el cambio aquí pondríamos
el cambio en sete verdad pero esto es lo
mismo que
por el cambiante - beta que multiplica
al cambio en x muy bien entonces ahora
cerramos nuestro paréntesis y para
conocer quién sería el cambio entre
prima verdad que es justamente lo que
necesitamos aquí podemos dividir en
todos lados entre ser verdad podemos
dividir en 13 en todos lados y así
podríamos obtener el cambio en de prima
verdad entonces lo que obtenemos es que
el cambio entre prima será justamente
gamma vamos a ponerlo aquí gamma que
multiplica a c por el cambiante dividido
en 13 será simplemente el cambio entre
menos beta dividido en 13 por el cambio
en x entonces nada más vamos a recordar
quién es beta beta es la velocidad
relativa dividido en 13 verdad entonces
si tenemos beta en 13 será
/ / se cuadrada de / / se cuadrada por
el cambio en x muy bien y ya podemos
cerrar nuestro paréntesis entonces ya
podemos usar la expresión para el cambio
entre prima verdad esto simplemente nos
quedaría entonces dividido entre gamma
gamma que multiplica al cambio ente al
cambio entre menos b sobre se cuadrada
por el cambio en x muy bien entonces ahí
lo tenemos esta es una forma de escribir
la velocidad verdad que lleva esta nave
pero en el marco de referencia s prima
muy bien entonces aquí lo que podemos
observar es que estas gamas se cancelan
verdad simplemente se cancelan y lo que
obtenemos es lo siguiente tenemos
que el cambio en x prima dividido entre
el k mente prima será igual al cambio en
x cambio en x menos aquí podríamos poner
beta que sería de dividido en 13 verdad
por el cambio en 7 que esto sería c por
el cambio en t verdad entonces las es se
cancelan y lo que podríamos simplemente
dejar sería cambio en x menos b por el
cambio ente así que vamos a ponerlo así
tal cual entonces tendríamos cambio en x
menos b por el cambio en t verdad y esto
irá dividido entre el cambio entre menos
b sobre se cuadrada cambio en x muy bien
entonces aquí el detalle es que nosotros
no conocemos quién es el cambio ente ni
tampoco sabemos quién es el cambio en x
lo único que sabemos es que digamos lo
único conocido es el cambio en x
dividido entre el cambio ente que es
nuestra velocidad
entonces lo que podemos hacer en esta
expresión para poder obtener esta
velocidad conocida es dividir en el
numerador y en el denominador entre
cambio ente verdad entonces esto sería
lo mismo que si dividimos en el
numerador por el cambio ente y también
en el denominador verdad sería
justamente cómo multiplicar por 1 entre
el cambiante dividido todo eso entre 1
entre el cambiante muy bien entonces
esto que será igual
bueno pues cambio en x / cambiante será
eso en cambio en x dividido entre
cambiante menos b por el cambio entre
dividido entre el cambio en t
simplemente nos queda b y esto va a
dividido entre cambiante entre cambio en
31 menos b sobre se cuadrada por el
cambio en x dividido entre el cambio en
muy bien entonces esto esto es una
expresión genial verdad porque podemos
calcular ahora la velocidad en el
sistema de referencia s prima pero en
términos de la velocidad relativa v que
ya teníamos verdad s desconocida está
esta vez la velocidad relativa entre el
sistema s prima y el sistema s y también
está tenemos aquí la velocidad digamos
de este de esta nave azul en mi marco de
referencia verdad que de hecho es cambio
en x entre cambios en t entonces como
esa le llamábamos y esto será igual a 1
- b dividido entre 1 - purves sobre
y cuadrada muy bien simplemente esto
será un y esto será fue lo único que
hemos hecho y esta fórmula es sumamente
útil la cual de hecho vamos a usar en
los próximos vídeos para que aprecien
qué tan divertido puede llegar a ser
hasta cierto nivel